hi i'd like to introduce myself i'm
justine i'm the queen of rap queen of
pop
ceo of every company creator of fire
creator of mankind
what else have you guys said i don't
even know but you guys are absolutely
out of control
hello hi uh i'm on tick tock right now
i've been obsessed with tick tock for
over a year and somehow over the past
i don't know like what a week a week and
a half
there has been this weird phenomenon
showing up in my for you page
ijustine memes did you really pay what
is this thing like 500. it was only 300
and i bought four of them for every room
that i would be in
i'll take that thank you a lot of memes
of some of my old videos making fun of
me but also like not making fun of me
i'm not really sure i don't know what's
happening either way
i am so here for it like honestly the
talent the creativity
the genius captions that you guys have
been coming up with
with videos that i have made over
16 years ago like when people say like i
can't even i
actually i can't even handle this me and
my sister and all my friends we have
been watching these
some of these are like feature films
that you guys have created on tik tok i
am
so impressed i've also been losing my
mind because there's these videos
that i haven't seen or even thought of
in so long that i
if you would have asked me if i made a
video doing that i probably would have
said no i didn't i didn't do that well
the proof is here
and it's on tick tock so i wanted to
react to some of these some of you guys
wanted to know if i'd seen them yes i've
seen them yes i love them and i think
that you guys
are incredibly talented so let's go
through and look at some of the ijustine
tiktok memes together
my entire fyp is ijustine and this audio
and i love it thank you zack i
appreciate it
oh boy oh oh oh did
did um did kesha see this and get
inspired to create her music
she outsold kesha with this not kesha
copying a song oh my god you guys are so
just this is just this is too much just
broke into ijustine's house
uh pretty sure that's an apple store but
i see i see where you're going with that
i mean like this these videos are so old
like who is she i don't even recognize
this person i don't recognize her it is
me
this was so long ago i basically used
the webcam of my laptop to make all of
my first youtube videos
so i think this video was actually the
first one that i saw and i i thought
that it was just going to be like a
super quick
little thing no no no no no no this is a
very long video especially by tick tock
standards
it just goes on and on i mean this is
like this could be like a broadway play
omg you guys i cannot wait to unbox all
of these new iphones for you
apple employees on the way to serve
their queen as i just answered the store
what did you create this with
i as a professional video editor over
the past 17
18 years this is skill this is talent
you have outsold everyone i have not you
right here with this
edit this is fire abandon us like you do
with every other phone the dialogue
is released yes you are irrelevant now
and i have no further use for you
i will dispose of you and your worthless
friends you no longer have any time on
this earth and you'll never feel the
touch of another human or hear the sound
of another voice
you have now been forgotten and all
memory of your existence has been wiped
clean you will not be missed you are
prehistoric technology now
goodbye what that was a monologue
i just see on our way to the apple store
for the fifth time today i don't speak
french i don't know what you're saying
this was a song that i wrote for siri it
was a love song
i don't know i could i'll let's forget
that we did that someone
there's an apple product down that cliff
queen justine
she jumps she does and she did someone
get my idol and iphone
oh geez this is when the eggplants were
all sold out
look at those eyebrows can we just take
a minute or a second
i don't want to take much longer than
that because that my friends
was an eyebrow mistake
i just seen trying to find lost phones
in the ocean so she can review it
like what i just seen on a way to get
the three brand new iphones the airpods
and the new macbook the second
it releases you're not wrong dancing her
way into getting a new imac
like what are these copies
i can't believe i posted this on the
internet first of all just seeing it on
with the apple store
five weeks before they released the new
iphone my god
oh shoot you know it this might have
been like one of the
the second or third ones that i saw
queen of rap
you can't change my mind um i think
anybody that watches this video can
easily be swayed
to know that that's something i could
not claim i just seen our way to the
apple store with his new iphone
also accurate live footage if i just
scene after dramatic tick-tock is
collectively dragging her apple
obsession
did you know about this this i feel
personally
attacked everyone digging out i just
need to get the new apple product
you guys digging me out of my grave good
this is what i deserved i didn't deserve
to be buried alive
escape the night look yeah bring me back
out
bring me back out so you can get the new
iphone i don't think they necessarily
run
usually i don't buy my things at the
store i usually buy them online so you
know
if i'm coming into the store probably
just to
say hi live footage if i just seen going
to buy another imac
oh my gosh what oh my god yeah i got
into a little drama with chrissy teigen
i honestly was not attacking her as a
fan of chrissy teigen i was just letting
her
know that as a youtuber the things that
she was saying was not quite reflective
of the community like i really i liked
her and then she attacked me and i was
like
what is this i just need waits in line
for a new iphone
[Music]
freaking love taylor swift that is a
good one
just some lightsaber fun what what what
what
it's like you're not wrong justine's
phone rings but she has to search
through 16 000
phones she has to find which one it is
so facts you didn't know about me
okay i'm a model
that's not that's not me that's that's
not me that's not me but it kind of
looks like what is happening
i'm a wrestler that's not too far off
that saw
this fits a perfect for that i might
have to steal that and
redo it how i justine became the queen
of apple
oh
[Music]
this is a gem i'm commenting on this one
truths dude i need to start commenting
on these that's what i need to be doing
i just seen in the sewers
looking for lost airpods to review what
oh my god why is that so funny
and why is this so true why do i picture
myself now running
to find the clearest sewer to find some
air pods
i just seen secret sun wouldn't that be
something wouldn't that be something
just it which seems the reason i'm an
iphone make america great 2024
picks up i just seen from 2007
oh my god what am i even doing
what am i even this is my first trip to
l.a
i just needed a way to free brittany
girl i will get her out
she can stay with me she can live with
me we would be besties for sure
introducing the new i oatmeal 5g m1500gb
zero sugars
so this was peak pandemic uh i unboxed
some cream of wheat
why truthfully i'm not sure okay so this
this is just
it's honestly never ending i am so
incredibly overwhelmed
there are so many of these i don't even
know what to say
the fact that you guys have been digging
up some of my old videos videos that i
don't even remember happened
it's basically taking me back to a time
remembering why i started making youtube
videos to begin with and it's one of the
reasons that i love tik tok
so much right now tik tok is sort of
this place where i feel like people can
be themselves they can be silly they can
be creative and it's where so many
people are finding their voice
and that reminds me so much of the old
school youtube days
seeing these old videos is really kind
of making me remember
what it was like then why i started
making videos i honestly started making
videos because
i grew up in a very small town and the
things that i liked there wasn't a lot
of people around that really
was like into computers or into video
games and when i found the internet
i found like this massive community of
people that liked
the same things that i liked now we
weren't all in the same area
but with the internet it felt like i had
found my community i had found
friends even if they were virtual and
far away and you guys have played such
huge part in that
and just knowing that so many of you
have grown up watching my videos
and even meeting some of you back in the
very beginning days like the first
vidcon and seeing you now many years
later like you're all grown up you guys
are in college you have careers you have
jobs you have families
it's really crazy how much has changed
in the landscape of the internet and in
people's lives
over the past 16 years and i'm so
appreciative that so many of you are
still here some of you knew some of you
old maybe some of you guys right in the
middle
either way thank you again for watching
and i hope that
someday you will see me vlogging from
the retirement home but the good thing
is i have a feeling that by the time
i'm into the retirement home i'm going
to have some other youtuber
or content creator friends there and
we'll probably
live stream our retirement home
endeavors oh
shoots all right that's it i'll see you
guys in my next video
or maybe i'll see you guys on tick tock
[Music]
bye